let's bring in dan bongino fox news
contributor former secret service agent
and former nypd officer hey dan
hey how are you good morning good
morning what's your reaction to that
i mean how is this not infuriating guys
i mean
this is a branch of government ted cruz
is a member of
of congress remember the united states
senate uh he's a duly elected senator
he represents one of the largest states
in the union texas
he's down there trying to just take on
videotape
for america to see what's happening at
their border
we own this it's our country it's not
joe biden's okay
it's ours are we not entitled to see
this and think of the nonsense
from that the press person or whoever
she was
she's a government employee which is
scary your tax dollars are paying her
to block a u.s senator from seeing
what's going on she says a couple things
there with her which are so absurd
you would think liberals would be losing
their minds too she says at one point
um this is not a zoo well i mean that's
obvious it's
not a zoo but why are you treating
people like animals then
you have them head to toe stacked in
plastic boxes you're watching the video
now guys i can see it on return
wrapped in literally not figuratively
wrapped in
literal emergency blankets and you're
claiming
it's not a zoo then again why are you
treating people like animals
this is the great irony of the left they
accuse you
of what they do and then they put
themselves on this
higher moral arc than you it's just
ridiculous i mean this is pravda stuff
here guys
seriously this is like old soviet union
type stuff
yeah i would just think every network
should be just as outraged when they
offer stock footage
or to see one sanitized facility as
opposed to those
chris wallace did a great job pressing
yesterday former nypd cop
i find this unbelievable new york is
ending qualified immunity for police
essentially
if the if somebody you arrest or detain
doesn't like the way you treat them
you could be sued yeah
yeah i have a i have a thought on this
you know congress has qualified immunity
too
they can go on the house floor and say
things and can't be prosecuted to spur
open debate
i say we take qualified immunity away
from them then you'd see a real debate
about qualified immunity this is
devastating
it is devastating having been a police
officer brian i have a strong
libertarian streak i am all about
accountability
for for police officers we should have
that and most good police officers
support that too
we already have a new york internal
affairs you have the civilian complaint
review board where if you walk in a
precinct you want to file a complaint
against a cop
and you're turned away that police
officer administrator made could be
fired for turning you away
now you want to open up police officers
when the course of their duties have to
engage in
all kinds of behavior normal people
don't fist fights on a daily basis for
people who attack police officers
now you want to open them up to lawsuits
this reminds me of thomas soule who
always says liberals never think of
second order effects
and then what what's gonna happen after
this you're gonna see a ferguson effect
on steroids
guaranteed oh man oh man another reason
why he moved from new york
to florida dan bungino thank you very
much for joining us live
thanks guys good talking